[Música]
el mundo empieza a notar las
consecuencias de la guerra en ucrania el
conflicto entre los exportadores de
trigo amenaza la seguridad alimentaria
especialmente en áfrica y los expertos
advierten sobre un levantamiento social
por los precios de los alimentos
régimen de excepción en el salvador la
medida entró en vigor tras ser
solicitada por el presidente en allí
bukele ante la ola de homicidios que
atraviesa el país sólo en los últimos
días 76 personas fueron asesinadas
el presidente brasileño ya y el bolsón
aro calienta motores de cara a las
elecciones presidenciales de octubre
transitario calificó la contienda
electoral como una lucha contra el mal
refiriéndose a las aspiraciones de la
izquierda
hola y bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
de noticias en france 24 los saluda
andrés meza muñoz empezamos hablando de
las consecuencias económicas que deja la
guerra en ucrania a raíz de la invasión
el aumento de los precios de la energía
es una prioridad pero otra urgencia ha
sido resaltada por el g7 se trata de la
seguridad alimentaria mundial los dos
grandes productores de trigo para europa
y áfrica están en guerra y sin el cereal
desde hace semanas los gobiernos
advierten de consecuencias dramáticas
un cereal que nutra el mundo entero el
trigo pero con la guerra en ucrania
estas espigas comienzan a acabarse en
algunas partes del mundo se comparte una
misma preocupación el riesgo de escasez
en los próximos meses rusia es el primer
país exportador a nivel mundial de trigo
ucrania el quinto entre los dos suman un
cuarto del comercio mundial desde el
comienzo de la guerra siete millones de
toneladas de trigo están a la espera en
dos principales puertos ucranianos el de
la asediada mariupol y sobre todo el de
o deza ley de bloque de hoy este trigo
está bloqueado en los campos ucrania
pero también en los puertos hoy ningún
barco parte de ucrania entonces se
bloquea el flujo del comercio
internacional de los granos comienzan
trasnacional de grama además para moscú
el trigo se ha vuelto imposible de
vender debido a las sanciones resultado
el precio aumenta
385 euros la tonelada un aumento de más
de 100 euros desde el comienzo del año
nosotros todos nos estamos enfrentando
al aumento de los precios pero también y
sobre todo estamos entrando en una
crisis alimentaria sin precedentes son
gc-2 una crisis alimentaria porque el
trigo se ha vuelto demasiado caro en
países como sudán somalia benin o
incluso indonesia ultra dependientes de
los stocks rusos y ucranianos unos como
lyon o turquía tienen reservas para
algunas semanas otros tienen suficiente
para aguantar algunos meses como egipto
aún así el gobierno intenta calmar a su
población con declaraciones como ésta en
el software codean con montos afebril
ayer a partir de abril tendremos el
stock suficiente para llenar nuestras
demandas no será útil comprar sobre los
mercados antes del final del año 2022
y si dicen estuve un día es porque hace
12 años la escasez de cereales causó un
especio social en los países árabes y
del medio oriente
tenemos un aumento de los precios
entonces se avecinan tensiones sociales
durante las próximas semanas en estos
países fuertemente dependientes porque
la comida faltará la comida de base
faltará o se pondrá drásticamente más
cara
a pesar de la guerra los agricultores
ucranianos comenzaron a sembrar esta
semana con la esperanza de que en
algunos meses pueden recolectar
tranquilamente pasamos al salvador donde
entró en vigencia el régimen de
excepción solicitado por el presidente
en allí bukele ante un aumento desmedido
de los homicidios sólo en los últimos
dos días 76 personas fueron asesinadas
la medida que regirá durante un mes
pretende hacer frente al rebote de
violencia por parte de las pandillas
un régimen de excepción en el salvador
por 30 días es el decreto que fue
aprobado este domingo por el congreso
limita la libertad de reunión y permite
los arrestos sin órdenes judiciales
entre otras cosas el presidente nayib
uke le pidió la medida en un contexto de
aumento de homicidios por parte de las
pandillas con 76 asesinatos en las
últimas 48 horas por mes está bueno que
han aprobado porque fíjese que ha
demasiado esta violencia este
mucho después están causando mayores se
había calmado esto permanece eso ya por
revancha está contra el gobierno cometer
homicidios permite las bandas criminales
afianzar su poder y les sirve de
mecanismo de negociación con el gobierno
hay una fuerte sospecha e indicios muy
muy fuertes también de una posible
negociación entre el gobierno y las
pandillas y esto puede ser quizá uno de
los orígenes de este incremento una
muestra de fuerza por parte de las
pandillas y una respuesta también del
gobierno ante esa demostración en un
estado ya considerado como altamente
autoritario el régimen de excepción
podría llevar a abusos y más control de
la población hay reportes ya de gente
que se le ha impedido salir de su casa
para poder hacer sus actividades
cotidianas y esto no es parte de la
aplicación del régimen que se aprobó en
la madrugada y por tanto es muy probable
que con instituciones altamente
represivas como la policía
los militares
tengamos un alza de abusos policiales y
militares en estos 10 hacia cerca de un
año busquen les destituyó de los jueces
de la corte suprema para imponer a
magistrados afines a sus intereses lo
que llevó a que varias organizaciones de
derechos humanos denunciarán el desvío
autoritario y en brasil el presidente ya
el bolsón aro pidió este domingo a sus
seguidores en un evento que luchen
contra el mal que relacionó con la
izquierda del país y que es representada
por el ex presidente luiz inácio lula da
silva quien todavía no ha presentado
oficialmente su candidatura para las
elecciones de este 2022 pese a las
especulaciones
ante miles de seguidores el presidente
de brasil el ultraderechista jair
bolsonaro habló sobre el supuesto
enemigo de brasil en una clara alusión a
las elecciones de este 2022 ya la
posible candidatura de levi's inácio
lula da silva a
nuestro enemigo no es externo es interno
no es una lucha de la izquierda contra
la derecha
es una lucha del bien contra el mal
grupo
[Aplausos]
y ganaremos esta batalla
bolsonaro convocó el evento con el
partido liberal al que se afilió en
noviembre para lanzar su candidatura
para los comicios de octubre según el
cronograma electoral la campaña para las
elecciones de octubre no puede comenzar
hasta el 16 de agosto pero si se
permiten eventos que son prácticamente
idénticos en este el mandatario
aprovechó para criticar el último sondeo
de datafolha que demuestra que lula da
silva acumula una intención de voto del
43 por ciento muy por delante de
bolsonaro al que se le adjudica un 26%
huapi una encuesta mentirosa pública a
mil veces no convertirá a nadie en
presidente de la república
un día ante su probable contrincante
para las elecciones lula dasilva
celebraba el centenario del partido
comunista que ya ha expresado su apoyo
al izquierdista si decide competir por
la presidencia
en 2022 se levantarán a las 7 de la
mañana
y
se darán un baño se peinará y sacarán a
bolsonaro de la presidencia de este país
de cara a los comicios de octubre brasil
enfrenta un aumento de la inflación ya
instalada y el precio del combustible
debido a la guerra en ucrania en un país
en el que más de 12 millones de personas
están desempleadas
los pueblos indígenas de canadá se
reunirán con el papá francisco esta
semana y durante su encuentro buscarán
disculpas desde el vaticano por los
abusos cometidos contra decenas de miles
de niños nativos en internados
financiados por el gobierno y
administrados en su mayoría por la
iglesia católica entre el siglo 19 y el
siglo 20
previamente hablamos con alberto
castagno periodista del medio natural
pres quien ha cubierto el tema y le
preguntamos por qué no ha habido una
respuesta del vaticano pese a las
repetidas solicitudes del gobierno
canadiense por una disculpa de la
iglesia católica
el primer ministro yo sin duda en 2017
le solicito por primera vez al papá
francisco en su visita al vaticano que
viniera a canadá a disculparse con las
comunidades indígenas las comunidades
mary's y nuits lo que es mal llamado
esquimales y las primeras naciones por
las fechorías de la iglesia católica
como lo han descrito esas mismas
comunidades indígenas sin embargo hasta
la fecha a pesar de que los obispos en
canadá han pedido perdón por los actos
cometidos entre
1831 y 1997 en aquellos colegios donde
pretendían matar el indio en el niño
como lo decían los mismos sacerdotes y
todavía no ha sucedido
y terminamos este informativo con los
ganadores de la edición número 94 de los
premios oscar y una sorpresiva victoria
para cauda como mejor película la mejor
dirección va a jane campion por su film
el poder del perro' es la segunda
estatuilla para la directora
neozelandesa
28 años después de the piano will smith
obtuvo su primer oscar a mejor actor por
su protagónico en el método williams el
actor desconcertó en la gala tras
propinarle un puñetazo a chris rock
quien se burló de su esposa la tres
veces nominada jessica testing se llevó
el galardón a mejor actriz en su
actuación o por su actuación en los ojos
de tamiflu mientras que en cantó se
lleva la mejor película animal
[Aplausos]
así despedimos este informativo en
france 24 gracias por acompañarnos
[Música]